my name is Sarah Samantha I'm the
editor-in-chief and vice president of
the board of editors of TV azteca
mexican television company and the
question that we reviewed in the session
the session is conclude to Rio plus 20
is how can business and government
actually renew their environmental
commitments on the road to the
conference of Rio plus 20 and of course
what we had in this meeting with were a
lot of differences there are some people
there are some environmentalists who
believe that there should be no growth
and the more growth and of course that's
something that would be not be
acceptable to business but here is me to
come conversing about the subject matter
after exchanging points of view everyone
seemed to come to the same agreement
everyone knows that we have to do
something we cannot keep on keep on
growing the way we've been growing many
of people independent also said is that
we have to keep on growing farkas
there's even a responsibility of
bringing the benefits of development
electricity education to billions of
people in the world or the solutions are
in DC and no one came up with a natural
solution at this time but it seems clear
that both business and non-government
organizations and governments are clear
that we have to do something we cannot
keep on growing the way we'd be going so
far